Entonces, ¿cuáles son las aplicaciones de la
tecnología de ADN? Muy bien, primero veamos la
medicina. ¿Cuáles son algunas aplicaciones de
la tecnología de ADN en la medicina? Las dos
grandes cosas en las que se utilizó por primera
vez la tecnología de ADN recombinante fue en la
creación de insulina y hormona de crecimiento
humano. Antes del advenimiento de la tecnología
de ADN recombinante, la insulina y la hormona del
crecimiento eran realmente difíciles de producir,
básicamente teníamos que aislarlas de otro
ser humano, purificarlas y luego dárselas
a los pacientes. Pero con la tecnología de ADN
recombinante podemos cultivar estas proteínas en
E.coli, podemos producirlos en un cultivo como el
de una bacteria E.coli, así que esto realmente ha
cambiado la forma en que se practica la medicina
y ha ayudado a un montón de personas. Las vacunas
son otra aplicación de la tecnología de ADN.
Hace un tiempo las vacunas se fabricaban primero
desnaturalizando la enfermedad y luego, después
de que la enfermedad se hubiera debilitado,
se inyectaba en un ser humano y se esperaba que
su sistema inmunitario pudiera luchar contra el
virus debilitado. De esa manera, en el futuro,
si se infectaba con ese virus al menos tendría
algún tipo de respuesta inmune contra el virus. El
problema con esto era que el paciente en ocasiones
contraía la enfermedad porque se le había
inyectado un virus débil, pero a veces no era
lo suficientemente débil. Ahora, con la tecnología
de ADN podemos recrear la capa externa del virus e
inyectar eso. Esto es mucho más rentable y no
tiene el riesgo de causar la enfermedad en el
hospedero; esto es mucho más seguro, más barato y
produce una mejor respuesta inmune. Algunas de las
vacunas que creamos utilizando tecnología de ADN
recombinante son las del virus de la hepatitis B,
el virus del herpes y la malaria. Éstas son
algunas aplicaciones de la tecnología de ADN
en la medicina. Otra aplicación genial de
la tecnología de ADN es resolver crímenes,
es decir, en la ciencia forense. Hay partes del
genoma conocidas como regiones no codificantes
del genoma, y estas regiones pueden ayudar
a los científicos forenses a identificar
individuos específicos, pueden ver cosas como
repeticiones cortas en tándem, STR. Éstas son
básicamente secuencias cortas de ADN, de 2
a 6 pares de base de largo, y normalmente
se encuentran en cantidades muy altas y en
diferentes cantidades en diferentes individuos,
por lo que si secuenciamos estas repeticiones
a corto plazo podríamos identificar individuos
específicos en una muestra de ADN. También pueden
observar el ADN mitocondrial. El ADN mitocondrial
se hereda de la madre y se encuentra en cantidades
realmente altas dentro de una célula individual,
entonces, incluso si hay muy poca muestra
disponible, los científicos forenses pueden
analizar el ADN mitocondrial para identificar un
posible sospechoso. Otra tecnología que utiliza la
ciencia forense es la tipificación del cromosoma
Y, que es Y-STR, es decir, repeticiones cortas en
tándem que se encuentran en el cromosoma Y. Por
lo tanto, la tecnología de ADN ha ayudado a los
científicos a identificar a individuos que han
cometido diversos delitos con base en muestras
de ADN que pudieron encontrar. La agricultura es
otro campo que se ha beneficiado enormemente de la
tecnología de ADN recombinante. Por ejemplo,
los científicos ahora pueden crear cultivos
que sean resistentes a los insectos y que sean
resistentes a los herbicidas, y también pueden
retrasar la maduración de los cultivos para poder
transportarlos de la granja a la tienda. Al hacer
esto, básicamente podemos tener más cultivos para
alimentar a una creciente población de individuos,
y también ayuda con la economía porque entonces
tenemos agricultores que tienen sus cultivos,
y si hubiera algún tipo de bacteria o virus que
los destruyera a todos, entonces, ese agricultor
no recibiría el pago por esa temporada. Así que
al modificar transgénicamente el cultivo para
que sea resistente a cosas específicas se puede
cultivar, vender y alimentar a las personas.